One thing about making commitments of action
is, I keep telling people: don’t make it
cast in stone.
When you go to the field keep asking questions.
And I remember I was responding to the children
who were abducted by the Lord’s Resistance
Army.
I was in northern Uganda and then I just kept
asking questions.
Then I asked, “What happened to the women
who went through the war?”
Because there was a lot of, you know, rape,
as a weapon of war.
And the local concert chairman told me okay,
there are 15 women.
So I took a bus to meet these 15 women because
some of them were raped, homeless.
So I just went to meet with them and I just
started asking questions.
First of all I said you are fifteen people,
you have one man in the group.
How is that?
And they told me that this man knows how to
read and write, so that’s why they have
him in the group.
Because when they talk about their issues
and all that there’s somebody who can read
and write.
So for me, that was already communication—that
the women do not know how to read and write.
So I thanked the gentleman for being part
of the team and I asked them which villages
they come from.
That’s when I started hearing stories of
homelessness.
One woman told me how her husband was abducted
and then the rebels used him to come and kill
his own people.
So in retaliation, his people sent her away
with her six daughters.
So you can imagine, every night they have
to look for where to sleep, to stay.
And woman after woman told me how they are
homeless.
So then I asked them a question: what does
it take to have a house?
Because those are, you know, grass thatched
houses.
And then they started to tell me it takes
grass, it takes water, it takes this.
I’m like, where can we get those things?
And then they started to tell me—so it’s
them actually getting their own ideas.
Then I told them, what do we require that
needs money?
So it came to nails, you know, things like
wood to make the doors and stuff like that.
But most of the things, the materials would
come from their own communities.
And for me I remember that day I said okay,
I’ll leave money for two huts—because
those are the houses.
And I say okay, in which order are we going
to get this housing?
So they also knew which woman was more desperate.
“Okay, this one who has more children and
this one doesn’t have anything.”
So they made their own decisions.
And then we started dividing roles:
“Okay, this is the money I have, so who
will keep this money?”
So we already got an accountant.
We had somebody in charge of water.
We had somebody in charge of cooking food
while the others are building.
And the next weekend —because it was urgent—it
dawned on us that some of the women did not
have land.
And we said okay, who can we ask for land?
Who has land in this village?
And they said oh, there’s a church.
So we went to see the head of the church.
We said okay, we need land.
So great enough so he offered some land for
women who didn’t have.
I started going back over weekends and actually
building the huts and through that mud while
others are collecting water.
So it was a scene in the village.
And so when the men saw us do that they got
embarrassed, and they would come and join
us as volunteers.
As we built we’re talking about issues of
peace.
We’re talking about issues of HIV Aids,
which were affecting them.
And then through the discussions—because
I wanted to find out: are the children going
to school, now that we have land?
That’s when it came to my mind that okay,
I’m going to offer to buy an ox plow and
then we can lend that to people who have the
cows, the cattle.
And then they can also lend us the cows in
turn so that they can pull the ox plow and
we plow our gardens in turns and collectively.
So when they do that and then they grow the
crops, so these crops can be sold and money
used for medicine and taking children to school.
That’s how the Huts for Peace program was
born.
I didn’t plan it, but at the Clinton Global
Initiative they teach us to be creative.
You meet very many people in this network
and you’re made very inspired.
So that’s how the Huts for Peace program
was born and I’m really happy about that.
Because it is their project.
Even as I sit here they continue building!
And they build communities and women knowing
that the power is in their hands.
And when women are given sources of responsibility,
before you know it they start campaigning
in the village and become village leaders.
So that is growth, and you see children going
to school, and you see involvement happening
by the people themselves.